ja ich bin ja das ist ich kann das Wort
ja nicht mehr hören ich bin unschuldig
Punkt
im Zuge des Verfahrens und im Laufe der
Jahre hat sie aber immer mehr aus seiner
Sicht verdichtet dass hier der falsche
Vorteil ist ich weiß noch wie absolut
geschockt ich war diese Gegend war so
vollkommen die wirkte so vollkommen
sicher ich glaube das wäre dann mal
zurück unschuldig ist jeder der das
Urteil liest merkt schnell es gibt keine
Beweise nur Indizien und auch die
Indizien sind mehr als dünn
der idyllische Ammersee am 15 September
ein zehnjähriges Mädchen wird auf dem
Nachhauseweg vom Fahrrad gerissen in
eine Kiste gesperrt und vergraben
[Musik]
die Familie soll zwei Millionen D-Mark
Lösegeld zahlen doch dazu kommt es nicht
die kleine Ursula stirbt vorher
ganz Deutschland hält den Atem an so ein
grausames Verbrechen hat es hier noch
nie gegeben
27 Jahre bleibt der Fall ungelöst erst
2010 verurteilt das Landgericht Augsburg
Werner matzurek zu lebenslange Haft bis
heute ist unklar ob der Täter alleine
handelte oder einen Komplizen hatte das
Urteil ist wacklig stützt sich
hauptsächlich auf ein umstrittenes
Tonband Gutachten und ein widerrufenes
Geständnis aber neue Gutachten könnten
jetzt seine Unschuld beweisen eine Spur
führt in einflussreiche Kreise bis zum
28 Mai entscheidet das Gericht ob Werner
matsurek vorzeitig aus dem Gefängnis
entlassen wird dann ist die
mindesthaftdauer von 15 Jahren um
draußen in Freiheit will der Verurteilte
Killer auf die Jagd nach dem für ihn
waren Killer gehen
[Musik]
bildreporterin Lena Zander fährt zu dem
Ort an dem Ursula Herrmann am ersten
Schultag nach den Sommerferien
verschwand sie kannte den Weg in und
auswendig so oft war Ursula Herrmann mit
ihrem Fahrrad schon von Schorndorf nach
Eching Gefahren sie war zuvor bei ihrer
Tante zum Abendessen sie setzt sich auf
ihr Fahrrad und will nach Hause doch
dort kommt das Mädchen nie an
Entführer reißen sie vom Fahrrad und
verschleppen sie in dieses Waldstück
zwischen 19:25 Uhr und 19.40 macht sich
Ursula Herrmann auf den Heimweg die
Entführer warten im Waldgebiet
Weingarten sprechen sich über einen
Klingeldraht den sie in die Äste
gespannt haben ab in einer Kurve wird
Ursula vom Fahrrad gerissen über
versteckte Trampelpfade wird die
Schülerin rund 800 Meter ins Waldstück
geschleppt dort sperren die Entführer
sie in eine Kiste und vergraben das
Mädchen
im Erdboden versenkte der Entführer eine
Holzkiste in der Ursula Herrmann sitzend
Platz hatte um ihr Überleben zu sichern
befestigte er auf dem Deckel extra ein
Belüftungssystem auch für Verpflegung
sorgte er mit Keksen und Wasser Bücher
und ein Radio sollten dem Mädchen unter
der Erde die Zeit vertreiben doch das
selbstgebaute Belüftungssystem
versagtagte entgegen der Absicht des
Entführers erstickte Ursel Hermann laut
eines Gutachtens nach nur kurzer Zeit
die Täter hatten die Entführung penibel
geplant sie werfen den ersten
Erpresserbrief mit Buchstaben aus
ausgeschnittenen Zeitungsartikeln in
Landsberg am Lech in den Briefkasten der
Erpresserbrief kommt bei Familie Hermann
an darin eine Lösegeldforderung von 2
Millionen D-Mark 11 mal rufen die
Entführer bei der Familie an und
Schweigen es ist nur das BAYERN 3 Signal
zu hören
[Musik]
dann bricht der Kontakt ab
gegen viertel vor zehn wird bei einer
umfangreichen Suchaktion die vergrabene
Kiste im Waldstück gefunden darin die
Leiche von Ursula das Mädchen war nach
kurzer Zeit erstickt
[Musik]
JVA Lübeck am 3 April 2023
Werner Mazurek verbüßt hier seine
Haftstrafe der 73-Jährige
Fernsehtechniker wurde am 25 März 2010
vom Landgericht Augsburg wegen
erpresserischen Menschenraubs mit
Todesfolge verurteilt
bild-reporterin Lena Zander besucht ihn
im Gefängnis wir dürfen ihn nur von
hinten Filmen an den Tag seiner
Verhaftung erinnert er sich noch ganz
genau
das war ein Heiliger Sonntag morgens um
6 Uhr
ich glaube wie viele waren da sechs Mann
vor der Tür
und ich dachte schon wieder Zeugen
Jehovas oder wer da immer kommt am
Sonntag
dürfen wir mal reinkommen und
Durchsuchungsbeschluss vorgezeigt die
ganze Bude auf dem Kopf gestellt war
nochmal zurück lebte in den 80er Jahren
am Ammersee in direkter Nachbarschaft zu
der Familie Hermann und zum Tatort nach
dem kurz nach der Tat ein anonymer
Hinweis auf ihn bei der Polizei einging
galt er schon früh als Hauptverdächtiger
doch die Indizien reichten damals nicht
aus um ihn anzuklagen der Fall Ursula
Herrmann wurde zum Code Case bevor das
Verbrechen nach 30 Jahren verjährt
wurden die Ermittlungen 2007 wieder
aufgenommen Werner mal zurück lebte
inzwischen in Norddeutschland die
Polizisten durchsuchten sein neues zu
Hause und beschlagnahmten ein
Tonbandgerät der Marke Grundig
tk248 mit gravierenden Folgen die
Ermittler ließen dazu ein Gutachten
anfertigen das Ergebnis es geht als
wahrscheinlich das mit einem solchen
Tonbandgerät das Bayern 3-signal
aufgezeichnet wurde dass bei den
schweigeanrufen der Familie Hermann
abgespielt wurde
[Musik]
Joachim Feller vertritt Michael Herrmann
den Bruder der Verstorbenen Ursula er
hat sich wie kein Zweiter mit dem Fall
seiner Schwester beschäftigt und
zweifelt an der Schuld von Werner zurück
Michael Hermann selbst möchte vor der
Kamera nicht sprechen dafür aber redet
sein Anwalt beide Halten eines der
beiden hauptindizien das von den
Ermittlern in Auftrag gegebene Tonband
Gutachten für wenig aussagekräftig
Feller erklärt
in die Sachverständige vom BKA
sagte dieses Tonbandgerät sei mit
Wahrscheinlichkeit verwandt worden und
dazu muss man eben wissen gibt da
unterschiedliche
Skalen sage ich mal die einige bis 6 die
ist hier verwandt worden und geben also
los mit an Sicherheit Grenzen
Wahrscheinlichkeit mit überwiegender
wahrscheinlich mit hoher
Wahrscheinlichkeit wahrscheinlich
wenig wahrscheinlich nicht
wahrscheinlich ja und die die
Sachverständige kam damals selbst nur
zudem zu der Einschätzung dass es gerade
vier sei ja also eine eine
Wahrscheinlichkeit die nach damaliger
auch damalige Rechtsprechung des
Bundesgerichtshofs alleine nicht hätte
dazu führen dürfen dass man darauf eine
Verurteilung stützt auch Werner
zurückbesteuert weiter seine Unschuld
bildreporterin Lena Zander fragt nach
das Thema Gerät war 2007 bei ihm
gefunden wo haben sie das her und wir
erzählten
2007 in Beverungen an der Weser auf
einem Flohmarkt für 20 € gekauft
das wüsste dann wäre ich nicht hier
und dann habe ich durch Zufall ein
Privatdetektiven gefunden
und der hat dann angefangen zu ermitteln
die Ermittler glauben Werner Matzek
nicht auch weil der vermeintliche
Verkäufer des tonbandgerätes nicht
auffindbar ist doch mal zurück gibt
nicht auf aus dem Gefängnis heraus
versucht er mit Hilfe des Detektiven den
Mann zu finden der seine Unschuld
beweisen könnte aber
kurz vorm Sieg stirbt der Mann aber es
ist auch eine mysteriöse Geschichte
das gibt so eine Trauerbrief aber es
gibt kein Grab hunderte von
seitenschrift Verkehr haben beide
ausgetauscht tausende Euro hat Werner
mal zurück dafür bezahlt ohne Ergebnis
2015 unterzieht sich mal zurück auch
einem Lügendetektor Test
den habe ich gemacht für die
Öffentlichkeit und für die Familie
Hermann
das hat 5000 € gekostet
und der ist einwandfrei doch auch das
reicht nicht aus um mal zu Rex Unschuld
zu beweisen denn nicht nur das 2007 bei
ihm gefundene Tonbandgerät belastet den
Fernsehtechniker er kann für den tatakt
zuerst kein Alibi angeben erst später
sagt er aus den Tag mit bekannten
verbracht zu haben doch die Ermittler
überzeugt das nicht denn ein anderer
bekannter belastet ihn schwer Klaus
Pfaffinger Gerät als mit Täter ins
Fadenkreuz im Februar 1982 sagte bei der
Polizei aus Werner matzurek habe ihn
beauftragt das Loch für die Kiste im
Waldgebiet zu graben aber sein
vermeintliches Geständnis ist in seiner
polizeilichen Vernehmung nicht
schriftlich festgehalten worden nur
wenige Stunden später widerruft der
inzwischen verstorbene Pfaffinger sein
Geständnis
Vorhalt sie haben im Vorgespräch
allerdings und das seit zugegeben auf
unsere drängenden Fragen schließlich
geantwortet sie hätten das Loch im
Weingarten in dem die Kiste der Ursula
Hermann versteckt worden ist im Auftrag
des mats zurückgegraben und er habe
ihnen dafür 1000 D-Mark und ein
Farbfernsehgerät versprochen dies möchte
ich wieder rufen es war nicht wahr was
ich da erzählt habe
ich weiß auch nicht warum ich matsurek
beschuldigt habe an dieser Stelle
erkläre ich noch mal dass er mich nie
aufgefordert hat für ihn ein Loch zu
graben und dass ich solche auch nie
getan habe
außerdem gab Klaus Pfaffinger an in den
Tagen vor seiner Vernehmung zehn
Flaschen Bier und zwei bis drei
Jägermeister am Tag konsumiert zu haben
[Musik]
der Kunde und Alki das war eine Arbeit
gehabt der war beim Fernsehstudio
München ne also beleuchte gearbeitet
ziemlich
geschluckt sagen wir mal so wenn es war
einmal zurück nicht gewesen sein sollte
wer war es dann in Untersuchungshaft
lernte er einen einflussreichen
Geschäftsmann kennen ihr glaubt laut mal
zurück ebenfalls an seine Unschuld
ja auf der Gartenarbeit
war damals für sein Alter recht fit
das war einer der gesagt ich weiß dass
du das nicht warst
diskutiert so was da schief erstmal die
ganze ermittlungspartner
haben wir mal durchgesprochen aber er
hat das selber genug Probleme gehabt und
es gibt eine weitere Verbindung Christa
von bernut ging in dasselbe Land Heim
wie der Sohn des Geschäftsmannes den
Mazurek im Gefängnis kennenlernte die
Journalistin und Autoren hat den
Entführungsfall damals hautnah miterlebt
sie erinnert sich
das Landheim ist nicht weit weg vom
Tatort und schon deswegen
war es eigentlich erstaunlich dass die
Polizei nicht das allererstes die
Schüler befragt schließlich stellte sich
auch heraus das ist ein Rechtsanwalt gab
der im Sinne des landheims das ganze
erstmal etwas verzögert hat man muss
dazu natürlich sagen
im Internat waren eben auch natürlich
die üblichen Söhne und Töchter reichere
Eltern und einflussreichere Eltern und
die hatten natürlich überhaupt kein
Interesse daran erstens mal dass ihre
Söhne oder Töchter in irgendeiner Form
unter Verdacht geraten aber natürlich
hatten auch das Landheim selber kein
Interesse daran so Mittelpunkt einer
Entführung mit Todesfolge zu werden bis
die Ermittlungen im Landheim anlaufen
Vergehen rund zwei Jahre und schließlich
aber wurden tatsächlich Schüler auch
befragt sie haben sogar ihre
Fingerabdrücke abgegeben und da gab es
dann einen weiteren Anwalt der dafür
gesorgt hat dass also da kein Link
hergestellt wurde zwischen den
Fingerabdrücken und den Namen erst wenn
es einen Match gegeben hätte dann wäre
es hätte man den Namen sozusagen
veröffentlichen dürfen aber es gab
keinen match was wir heute nicht wissen
bis heute nicht wissen ist haben
wirklich alle Schüler ihre
Fingerabdrücke abgegeben endlich kommt
wieder Bewegung in den Fall im Januar
1983 gab es eine weitere Untersuchung im
Landheim
niemand verstand zu Recht warum zu
diesem Zeitpunkt denn das Verbrechen lag
ja da schon zwei Jahre zurück und zwei
Schüler kamen dann freiwillig sozusagen
aus freien Stücken kamen auf die
Polizisten zu und haben ihm gesagt wir
haben das hier gefunden und das
entpuppte sich als ein klingeltraut
die beiden Schüler erzählen der Polizei
sie hätten den Klingeldraht im
Weingarten gefunden sie sagen aus wir
haben das gefunden im Wald als wir auf
eulenjagd waren tagsüber und aber erst
vor kurzem und die Polizei wusste zu dem
Zeitpunkt noch gar nicht dass dieser
Klingel Draht von einer gewissen
Bedeutung war so dass es merkwürdig war
dass die beiden Schüler aus freien
Stücken zu diesen Polizisten gekommen
sind und Ihnen diesen Klingel gerade
ausgehändigt haben und weil sie
eigentlich zu dem Zeitpunkt gar nicht
wissen konnten was für eine Bedeutung
dieser Klingel gerade in dem Verbrechen
hatte dass er eine Bedeutung hatte hat
sich dann später herausgestellt bei der
anschließenden Untersuchung finden die
Ermittler raus die Täter hatten den
Klingeldraht vermutlich über den
weingartenweg gespannt um miteinander zu
kommunizieren die beiden Schüler werden
als Zeugen vernommen bei der Polizei
sagen sie auch aus dass sie die geheimen
Trampelpfade die die Entführer im
Waldstück benutzten um Ursula Herrmann
zur Kiste zu schaffen Kanten aber auch
das gibt den Ermittlern keinen Anlass
weiter in diese Richtung zu ermitteln
Christa von bermut erinnert sich an
diese beiden Mitschüler besonders einer
ist ihr im Gedächtnis geblieben es war
ein eher schüchterner Junge ich habe
mich festgestellt dass er gemobbt wurde
aber er war jemand der nicht unbedingt
sehr beliebt war er war eher
zurückgezogen und er hatte eben einen
engen Freund das war der andere Schüler
der diesen Klingel gerade mit ihm
zusammengebracht hat und
das Merkwürdige an diesen beiden
Persönlichkeiten war dass der eine
also auf mich eher unsportlich
vielleicht leicht übergewichtig und so
also meine Erinnerung kann mich täuschen
aber so leicht übergewichtig dicke
Brille also all das ähm was früher als
nicht so wirklich attraktiv galt
eines ist der ehemaligen Mitschülerin
noch ganz genau im Gedächtnis geblieben
das wurde mir später erzählt das wusste
ich zu der Zeit nicht ist das einer der
beiden Waffen hatte diese Waffen auch
ins Landheim mitgebracht hat und das
beide wohl Waffen affin waren und wohl
auch im weingartengebiet ab und zu
geschossen haben
nach bildrecherchen handelt es sich bei
einem Schüler um den Sohn des
Geschäftsmannes ihr wurde von den
Ermittlern als Zeuge vernommen und es
gibt noch eine weitere Auffälligkeit auf
der Holzkiste in der Ursula Hermann
vergraben wurde befand sich eine
Silberlegierung und eine Bitumenschicht
Bitumen wird unter anderem für
Straßenmarkierungen benutzt die
Ermittler schrieben hunderte Firmen an
um den Ursprung dieser Beschichtung in
Erfahrung zu bringen nach
Bildinformationen handelt es sich
hierbei um die straßenmarkierungsfirma
des ehemaligen Mithäftlings von Matzek
die Firma lag zufällig nur wenige
Kilometer vom Tatort entfernt
Barbara Zipser beschäftigt sich seit
Jahren mit dem fallursula Herrmann die
in London lebende
Sprachwissenschaftlerin hat gemeinsam
mit Ursulas Bruder Michael Herrmann alle
Akten studiert und ausgewertet
bildreporterin Lena Zander spricht mit
ihr wir Zoom an der Kiste wurden Farben
und auch Farbspritzer festgestellt die
hoch auffällig waren es handelte sich
dabei um Prototypen die nicht im Handel
erhältlich waren aber das konnte nicht
geklärt werden wo diese Lacke herkommen
es gibt ganz in der Nähe des Tatortes
eine Firma in der ähnliche Lacke
entwickelt wurden wir wissen nicht ob
die Firma untersucht wurde sie wurde
aber für ein Fachgespräch hinzugezogen
was ein Fachgespräch in diesem
Zusammenhang zu bedeuten hat bleibt
offen auch in den Ermittlungsakten gibt
es darauf keine Antwort nach
Bildinformationen handelt es sich
hierbei um die straßenmarkierungsfirma
des ehemaligen Mithäftlings von matsorek
zu Werner matsurek jedenfalls lässt sich
hierzu kein Bezug ableiten auch die
Erpresserbriefe sprechen eine andere
Sprache
Barbara Zipser hat diese begutachtet und
anhand der Erpresserbriefe ein Profil
des vermeintlichen Täters erstellt dabei
stellte sie fest hör mal zurück passt
altersgemäß gerade noch so in das Profil
hinein ansonsten aber nicht
es gibt da verschiedene Merkmale also
zum Beispiel Satzbau
Wortwahl und verschiedene andere Dinge
ihn konnte ich doch recht sicher
ausschließen auf einem Durchschlag
findet Zipser Zeichen die aussehen wie
eine matte Aufgabe aus der Oberstufe wie
passt das zu Mazurek als Täter die
Sprachwissenschaftlerin glaubt es ist
offensichtlich ein sehr naiver und
unerfahrener Täter
1981 gab es die Diana Analyse in der
Forensik noch nicht es gab aber
sicherlich eine Phase Analyse und mit
einer solchen Collage Technik fängt man
sich sehr viel Spuren ein insofern war
das jetzt keine besonders
schlaue Art einen Erpresserbrief zu
schreiben und es gibt weitere
Ungereimtheiten weder auf der Kiste noch
auf den erpresserbriefen oder anderen
asservaten die mit der Tat zu tun haben
wurden Fingerabdrücke oder die DNA von
Werner mal zurück gefunden inzwischen
liegt auch ein neues Tonband Gutachten
vor Experten der forensischen Phonetik
an der Universität Zürich geben an dass
die Wahrscheinlichkeit dass das
Tonbandgerät ein Tatwerkzeug gewesen sei
minimal ist es taucht ein
Bekennerschreiben auf unterschrieben mit
dem Namen des Sohnes von matsorex
ehemaliger Gefängnis Bekanntschaft im
November 2020 bekam Joachim Zeller das
ist der Anwalt von Michael Hermann ein
schreiben was aber auffällt ist dass in
diesem vermeintlichen Bekennerschreiben
doch Details genannt werden die so in
der Presse nicht veröffentlicht wurden
das heißt dass da auch mehr Wissen
hinter steckt auf bildanfrage erklärt
die Staatsanwaltschaft Augsburg das
Schreiben ist unglaubwürdig offenbar
wollte ihn jemand anschwarzen aber warum
bis heute bleiben viele Fragen offen
Werner Mats zurück will trotzdem kämpfen
ich werde es probieren durch ein
Wiederaufnahmeverfahren dass die
Wahrheit ans Licht kommt oder zumindest
erstmal die Weite ich das nicht war aber
schauen wir mal
wegen deinem Profil ich weiß es nicht
für die Staatsanwaltschaft ist der Fall
jedoch abgeschlossen auf eine weitere
bildanfrage wollte sie sich nicht mehr
äußern der Fall sei geklärt der Täter
verurteilt und das Verbrechen nach 30
Jahren sowieso verjährt
[Musik]
Werner zurück kann sich damit nicht
abfinden ja ich spring da nicht jemand
eine gute rum mir ist so innerlicher
Zorn Gottes der älter der lebendig
ihre hängen lassen und
Mario nicht auch Ursel Hermanns großer
Bruder Michael gibt keine Ruhe er hat
Zweifel daran dass mit Werner matsurek
der wahre Täter hinter Gittern sitzt ihr
und sein Anwalt Joachim Feller wollen
dafür kämpfen dass im Fall Ursula
Herrmann die Ermittlungen wieder
aufgenommen werden er war mit manchen
Dingen die im Strafprozess waren
überhaupt nicht einverstanden es war
nicht nachvollziehbar für ihn und so
entstand dann die Idee dass man ein
Zivilverfahren anstrengt indem man den
zunächst rechtskräftiger bereits
vorurteilten einmal zurück auf
Schmerzensgeld verklagt ohne Erfolg das
Gericht ordnete keine neue
Beweisaufnahme an im Zuge des Verfahrens
und im Laufe der Jahre hat sie aber
immer mehr aus seiner Sicht verdichtet
dass hier der falsche Vorteil ist
aber wofür den wahren Täter finden wenn
er nicht mehr verurteilt werden kann
Hermann und sein anwaltte sammeln
Beweise dass es sich beim Tod von Ursula
Herrmann um Mord handeln könnte laut
eines forensikers könnte das Mädchen mit
Lachgas betäubt und an den Folgen
gestorben sein damit hätte der Täter
billigend Ursula ist tot in Kauf
genommen das wäre Mord und Mord verjährt
bekanntlich nie
[Musik]
werner mazzurek hat sein Leben nach der
Haft schon akribisch geplant ich habe
eine Wohnung
seit vier Monaten behindertengerecht ich
habe ein Fahrzeug ich habe eine Papiere
in Ordnung ich habe alles draußen in
Freiheit will er auf die Jagd gehen und
endlich seine Unschuld beweisen
[Musik]